UNVEILED ON HIS PODCAST
YESTERDAY HIS TOP CORNERS AND
HIS TOP SAFETIES ENTERING
THE DRAFT.
AND I DON'T SEE JC HORN ON.
LIST OF TOP CORNERS, SO
ONE OF THE EXPERTS HE'S
ALREADY CALLING OUT HERE.
YEAH, CHRIS WRIGHT ICE. HE'S
KEEPING A LIST LIKE RYAN IN
THE OFFICE WHEN YOU KNOW, HE
HAD HIS DOWNFALL AND HE'S GOT
HIS PEN AND PAPER AND HE
MARKS THE YOU KNOW, HE'S
MARKS OFF THE NAME OF EVERY
ONE WHO HAS WRONGED HIM. WHY
IS HE NOT ON YOUR LIST - A
LIST CHECKING IT TWICE TRYING
TO FIND OUT WHO'S NAUGHTY AND
NICE. THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
RIGHT? I MEAN FIRST OFF. I
LIKE THE PLAYER I DO HE'S GOT
I DO HE'S GOT INCREDIBLE SIZE.
AS AND STRENGTH COMBINATION
THAT'S WHERE HE IS. BUT TO ME
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, YOU HEARD MY
LITTLE EXPLANATION A LITTLE
BIT ON MY PODCAST AND WHAT I
LOOK FOR IN CORNERS, THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH TOP END SPEED FOR
ME TO MAKE HIM A FIRST ROUND
CORNER. HE'S A SPECIALIZED
CORNER. HE'D HAVE TO PLAY AND
MAYBE A SEATTLE SCHEME OR
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO MATCH
UP AGAINST ONLY THE BIG
RECEIVERS OR THE TIGHT ENDS
TO ME. IT'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
PURE. SO LIKE STRAIGHT AHEAD
EXPLOSION NOT GOOD ENOUGH
AT COMING OUT OF
CUTS AND AND ACCELERATING TO
BREAK ON THE BALL, YOU KNOW,
IT'S JUST THAT THAT'S MY
CONCERN THERE AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M ABOUT WITH CORNER. HEY,
YOU KNOW, THAT'S AGAIN WHERE
I GO TO CORNER YOU TALK ABOUT
THE TOP CORNERS AND FOOTBALL,
YOU KNOW IN THE HISTORY OF
THE SPORT TO THEY'RE RUNNING
FORWARD THREE, THEY'RE
RUNNING LOW FOR FOURS AND
THEY PLAY FASTER THAN THE LOW
FOR FOR WHEN YOU'RE RUNNING
FOR FIVE OR HIGH FOR FOURS OR
YOU'RE GOING TO HOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE GOING
TO COVER ODELL BECKHAM JR. IS
OF THE WORLD AND STEFON DIGGS
AND THOSE GUYS. NO YOU'RE NOT
AND THAT'S WHERE I ALWAYS
COME BACK TO AND TO ME. YES.
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE THING I
LOOK FOR IT IS SUCH A
CRITICAL POSITION. IT IS SO
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THE
RECEIVER ALWAYS KNOWS WHERE
HE'S GOING, RIGHT THE CORNER
DOESN'T AND THERE'S ONLY SO
MUCH YOU CAN GLEAN FROM FILM
STUDY. THE BEST RECEIVERS ARE
NOT GOING TO HAVE ANY TELLS
ANY INDICATION ANY HINT AS TO
YOU THAT THE GOING OUT WHEN
THEY GO IN RIGHT TRYING TO
SELL YOU THE GOING SHORT WHEN
THEY GO LONG AND THEY ARE
INCREDIBLE PHYSICAL SPECIMENS
AND YOU ARE TOO BUT THEY HAVE
THE ADVANTAGE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW WHERE THEY'RE GOING AND
IT IS A NATURAL DISADVANTAGE
AND I THINK IT MAKES IT EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS
TO GRAVITATE TOWARD FAST GUYS
WHO CAN RECOVER WHEN THE
RECEIVER ZIGS WHEN THE
CORNER THOUGHT MAYBE HE WOULD
ZAG GILMORE GYRE ALEXANDER,
MARSHAWN
LATTIMORE
YOU KNOW MARLON HUMPHREY
WILLIAM JACKSON WHO JUST
SIGNED A BIG CONTRACT BYRON
JONES. THEY'RE ALL HIGH FOR
THREE GUYS. THEY'RE ALL HIGH
FOR THREE GUYS. HOW DO YOU
EXPECT A GUY TO COVER A GUY
WHO RUNS FOR THREE OR FOUR
FOUR FLAT WHEN THE GUY
COVERING HIM? LIKE YOU SAID
DOESN'T KNOW WHERE HE'S GOING
AND HE RUNS FOR FIVE, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S THE BIG THING
AND YOU KNOW, LIKE WE HAVE A
QUESTION FROM AT KMART 2180.
I WANT TO READ THIS HE GOES.
WHERE DO YOU RANK OR WHERE DO
YOU RANK JC HORN? IF HE'S NOT
IN YOUR TOP SIX, I'M
SO CONFUSED WITH YOUR
EMPHASIS ON SPEED RICHARD
SHERMAN ALWAYS RANKS AS THE
TOP CORNER BACK IN EVERY
CATEGORY AND HE'S NOT AS
BLAZING SPEED MAN. YEAH. HE'S
A SYSTEM FIT. HE IS A SYSTEM
FIT. THERE'S A REASON YOU'VE
ONLY SEEN THEM IN THE SEATTLE
SCHEME BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
HE'S NOT A GREAT MAN TO MAN
CORNER IF HE HAD A PLAY IN
BALTIMORE OR NEW ENGLAND OR OR
OR KANSAS CITY AS MUCH AS
THEY PLAY MAN-TO-MAN. IT
AIN'T GONNA WORK BUDDY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TELLING YOU
SO THAT TO ME.
ME, YOU KNOW AGAIN, I REALLY
LIKE RICHARD SHERMAN. HE'S
GOING TO THE HALL OF FAME BUT
FOR ME TO HE'S ALSO A HAIR
OVER RATED THAT WAY BECAUSE
IT IS ONLY A SYSTEM THAT I
BRING GUYS TO GO. THEY FIT IN
ANY SYSTEM MAN-TO-MAN EVERY
PLAY. THEY COULD PLAY THE
SEATTLE SCHEME IF THEY HAD TO
BUT REALLY SEATTLE SCHEMES.
THEY DON'T LOOK TOO THEY
DON'T LOOK TO GET USUALLY
TOP-END CORNERS A WHOLE LOT
BECAUSE THEY GO WE DON'T PLAY
MAN. SO I DON'T WANT TO GET A
TOP END CORNER, YOU KNOW, SO
THAT'S MY ANSWER TO THAT. I
LIKE
HORN HE'S RIGHT PAST THOSE
TOP SIX, BUT YES, HE'S
NOT A FIRST-ROUND TALENT
JUST BECAUSE OF THAT, YOU
KNOW LACK OF WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT THEIR OF THE CORNERS
AND WE'VE GOT THE LIST. WE'LL
PUT IT BACK UP WHICH OF THE
ONES THAT YOU'VE EVALUATED
REMINDS YOU OF ONE OF THE
BEST CORNERS CURRENTLY IN
FOOTBALL RAMS QUARTERBACK
JALEN RAMS. IT'S THE GUY
RIGHT AT THE TOP THERE MIKE
THIS THIS KIDS THE REAL DEAL
HOLYFIELD, YOU KNOW, CALEB
FARLEY FROM VIRGINIA TECH. HE
DIDN'T PLAY LAST YEAR, BUT
HEY WE
SAW JEFFREY A CUDA GO AT
NUMBER THREE LAST YEAR AND I
GO WELL, THEN THIS GUY COULD
GO NUMBER ONE. I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN THIS GUY'S OH, HE'S A
FREAK. I HAVE NOT SEEN A
CORNER THIS BIG BE ABLE TO
MOVE LIKE THIS SINCE JALEN
RAMSEY AND A LOT OF WAYS AND
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THIS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, I GOT A MAN
CRUSH ON JALEN RAMSEY. HE
MOVES BETTER THAN JALEN
RAMSEY DID COMING OUT OF
FLORIDA STATE. I WAS BLOWN
AWAY. I KNEW THERE WAS HYPE
AROUND THIS GUY, BUT WHEN I
TURNED IT ON I JUST WENT WHOA,
BIG HE CAN FLY HE COULD STICK
HIS FOOT IN THE GROUND AND
DRIVE ON THE BALL LIKE A
TOP-TIER WIDE RECEIVER. HE'S
GOT REALLY GOOD BALL SKILLS,
AND HE'S KIND OF JUST DOING
IT RAW LIKE HE HASN'T BEEN
TAUGHT A WHOLE LOT YET AND
MIKE I'M BIG ON THE AGAIN
GOING BACK TO THE ASPECT OF
LIKE, HEY, YOU GOT THAT GUY
WHEN I SEE COLLEGES START
DOING THAT I GO. OH, THEY
KNOW HE'S KIND OF SPECIAL HE
CAN DO THAT AND HE'S ONE OF
QUESTION ANSWER TAKE CALEB
FARLEY OVER ZACH WILSON. HA
HA HA. NO, I WOULD NOT AND A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE OF THE
REASON FIRST OFF, YOU KNOW, I
LOVE ZACH WILSON. I THINK
HE'S SUPER STAR BUT THE
JETS ARE GOING TO RUN THAT
SEATTLE SCHEME. THEY'RE NOT A
HUGE MAN-TO-MAN FOOTBALL TEAM.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY DO. SO
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO VALUE A NUMBER TWO PICK
FOR THE CORNER POSITION LIKE
THAT. LET'S TALK ABOUT SAFETY
FOR A MINUTE OR TWO. WE HAVE
THE BOARD OF YOUR
MAKINGS THERE MY QUESTION IS
WHICH ONE REMINDS YOU OF
JAMAL ATOMS AND MY GUESS IS
WHOEVER IT IS. HE'S PROBABLY
THE TOP GUY ON YOUR LIST.
THAT'S RIGHT. YEAH. YEAH. I
MEAN, YOU'RE RIGHT. I THINK
IT WOULD BE CISCO IS LIKE THAT
PROTOTYPE ANDRE CISCO FROM
SYRACUSE. IS THAT
PROTOTYPICAL GUY NOW HERE
THERE'S A LITTLE YOU KNOW,
HITCH IN THE GIDDY UP HERE
BECAUSE HE TORE HIS ACL, YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR BUT MAN WHEN
YOU TALK WHEN I'M TOO WHEN
WE'RE SAYING LIKE JAMAL ATOMS
AND YOU ASKED ME THAT
I GOT GREAT SPEED A BALL HAWK
AND WILL ABSOLUTELY KNOCK
YOUR HEAD OFF IF YOU COME
INTO THE HOLE OR THERE'S A
PULLING GUARD OR DOING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. CISCO IS
LIKE THAT CISCO'S GUY CROCKED
UP LIKE A JAMAL ATOMS AND YOU
GOTTA BE IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
THAT TYPE OF SAFETY AND I
WOULD SAY WITH JAMAL ADAMS.
MAYBE HE'S NOT QUITE AS A
GOOD HAS OR NOT AS BIG AS
JAMAL, BUT HE'S FASTER THAN
JAMAL CISCO IS ONE OF THOSE
GUYS WHEN YOU TURN ON THE
FILM YOU GO. I THINK HE
MIGHT RUN FOR THREE EIGHT
FOUR THREE NINE.
LIKE THAT, HE'S THAT KIND OF
SPEED HE WAS HE WAS REALLY
SPECIAL. I'M A BIG FAN OF HIS.
THINK THE ONLY THING I
QUESTION IS JUST YOU KNOW,
WHERE TEAMS FEEL ABOUT HIS
INJURY AND STUFF LIKE THAT JC
HORN IS THE SON OF SAINTS
RECEIVER, JOE HORN. YEAH
TRICK CERTEYN THE SECOND
ALABAMA CORNER THE SON OF
PATRICK CERTEYN WHO WAS A
GREAT CORNER IN HIS DAY. WHAT
DO YOU WHAT DO YOU SEE IN
HIM? WELL, I MEAN
HE'S HE IS A TECHNICIAN AND
WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
YESTERDAY RIGHT BECAUSE OF
HIS PRO DAY AND STUFF. I MEAN
THE SIZE, YOU KNOW,
UNBELIEVABLE HIPS. HE'S GREAT
AT AGAIN BEING ABLE TO PUT
HIS FOOT IN THE GROUND AND
NOT TAKE A LOT OF WASTED
STEPS AND DRIVE ON THE BALL.
THE MY ONLY CONCERN WAS
CERTEYN IS WHAT YOU HEARD
YESTERDAY. AND THIS IS WHY I
HAVE HIM NUMBER THREE BEHIND
TYSON CAMPBELL AND CALEB
FARLEY IS JUST THE PURE SPEED
ELEMENT. YOU KNOW, I KNOW HE
WHAT THE AT HIS PRO DAY? I
WOULD GET IN LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYBODY 442 WAS 452 AT THE
BUYING ALL THE REALLY SMART
DEFENSIVE COACHES AND
SECONDARY COACHES ARE GOING
TO ADD A TENT THAT TIME TO GO
THAT'S NOT REAL 442 IT YOUR
PRO DAY IS NOT NOT THE SAME
THING. SO, HE'S A TOP 15 PICK.
I'M I REALLY LIKE THE GUY
BUT AS FAR AS LIKE CALEB
FARLEY OR THE GUY TYSON
CAMPBELL IN FRONT OF THEM WHO
HAS A LOT OF THE SAME
MEASURABLES. HE DOES, YOU
KNOW, THEY JUST HAVE BETTER
PURE SPEED AND ACCELERATION
AND EXPLOSION AND THAT'S WHY
OVERALL THIS CLASS, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW MANY
GREAT RECEIVERS THERE ARE
THERE'S GOING TO BE A BUNCH
OF QUARTERBACKS IN ROUND ONE
THIS CLASS OF CORNERS AND
SAFETIES. HOW DOES IT COMPARE
TO OTHERS? YEAH. THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION. I THINK THE
THE THE TOP-END CORNERS ARE
REALLY DAMN GOOD LIKE I LIKE
THESE THREE CALEB BARLEY
TYSON CAMPBELL AND CERTEYN
BETTER THAN I'D LIKE THE TOP
THREE LAST YEAR AND I WAS A
BIG FAN OF YOU KNOW, EJ
HENDERSON AND AND AJ TYRELL,
I LOVE THEM. I MEAN, I RANK
THEM IN FRONT OF THE CUDA. I
THINK THESE THREE ARE PRETTY
SPECIAL I WILL SAY AT THE
CORNER POSITION. I THINK
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
DROP OFF AFTER THESE SIX
SAFETY THIS YEAR MIKE. THAT
WAS THE ONE WHERE I JUST FELT
LIKE IT WAS A NEVER-ENDING
LIST. I WAS ONE WHERE I KEPT
LOOKING AT IT GOING MAN.
HERE'S ANOTHER GOOD ONE. WHOA,
HE'S NUMBER NINE ON MY LIST
HERE, BUT HE'S GOING TO BE HE
COULD BE A STARTER NEXT YEAR
AND BE GOOD FOR A FOOTBALL
TEAM. SO THE SAFETY IS THE
POSITION WHERE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF GUYS THAT
HAVE VERSATILITY ASPECTS AND
IT'S JUST GOING TO BE ABOUT
HOW THEY WANT TO USE THEM ALL
TOGETHER LAS